[Musique]
au cinéma le grenier à sel nous vous
proposons les choses qu'on dit les
choses qu'on fait c'est un film fait
partie de la sélection officielle du
festival de cannes 2020 évidemment le
festival n'a pas eu lieu mais il a quand
même ce label label festival donc c'est
un gage de qualité quand même ce film
est porté par des acteurs épatants comme
camélia jordana vincent mccain les
milices de kent dick cheney schneider le
réalisateur c'est emmanuel mouret c'est
un réalisateur français que l'on suit
nous au grenier à sel depuis ses
premiers films
il a notamment réalisé
mademoiselle de jonquière avec cécile de
france edouard baer qui était sorti fin
2018 emmanuel mouret sait il est aussi
connu et surtout connu pour ses comédies
d'amour à la marivaux et ce film là
aujourd'hui c'est dans la même veine
puisqu'il s'agit d'un chassé croisé
amoureux avec des amendes et maîtresses
des trio amoureux des secrets il ya donc
des histoires légères et des histoires
plus grave mais au final elles finissent
par se condenser dans un seul récit
c'est un peu une fresque sentimentale
avec thé où les combinaisons
sentimentale se nouent et se dénouent
moi je trouve que c'est un film
magnifiquement interprété qui a trouvé
sa place sur nos grands écrans et il a
aujourd'hui une très belle presse un
super bouche à oreille et c'est vraiment
tant mieux ça fait plaisir à voir
alors vous aussi vous pouvez venir le
voir dans notre salle au grenier à sel
[Musique]